all right Mike yeah Mike uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I'm born and raised in uh Los Angeles
California
um my mom had me at the USC LA County
General Hospital then uh we lived on
29th and Normandy
and my father tells the story of in 65
born in 1965.
that uh
three months after I was born they had
the Watts Riots
and um
you know that was a racial racial Riot
against the blacks and the police
it was pretty bad my dad said
he took me and my other brother Damien
and and my mom and put us in the closet
and stood there by the door holding his
22 rifle
my father's White Irish he was born in
Dublin Ireland his name is Michael Baker
O'Connor my mom is African-American she
was born in Indianapolis Indiana
um
both were in the music industry they met
in their careers at the troubadour
my mom was singing my dad was playing
drums and that's where they met
um
my father uh
um was raised in Beverly Hills
California on a street called Copley his
uh his father is Raymond Manning
O'Connor who was the vice president of
Universal Studios in the 50s and 60s
when my dad married my mom
my grandfather Raymond disinherited my
dad because she was a black woman and um
and was born with was born with me uh
I'm Michael Baker O'Connor Jr so that
was my dad's first
um but he was disinherited from the
O'Connor whatever money they had that
was coming in it's all kinds of all
kinds of [__] that that was involved
with this because my mom eventually
uh fights to get the rights for her sons
six boys
Damien myself Shane Scott
Gavin and Manning all O'Connors and
every O'Connor at a certain age as a
trust fund in the Colgate uh Enterprise
because our great great grandfather
Diggory O'Connor was one of the founders
or CEOs or whatever of Colgate
none of the black kids got any of that
trust fund money because my father was
disinherited by his his father
my mom went on Oprah Winfrey to talk
about this [__] and uh the most
embarrassing thing that I had to go
through because in school all my friends
are like your mom was on Oprah and you
guys are because my my parents get
divorced at I was 12. we lived on Lanier
Lane uh Coldwater Canyon Beverly Hills
my neighbors our neighbors was Neil
Diamond on one side and Phillip Bailey
from Earth 105 on the other side we had
the middle house the big house on the
top but when my dad leaves my mom
uh at 12 it was living one way and then
living completely the opposite it was
tencent bread welfare cheese my father
hid all his money and switched accounts
so my mom got nothing
she had nothing she had six six children
six boys
and uh and no money
we moved down to Beverly Drive
which is on the other end of Beverly
Hills it's out adjacent to Beverly Hills
and it's uh closer to I didn't mind I I
really didn't understand any of this
[__]
um but when I do some therapy and and
look back on my life and where did
things go wrong for me uh because I'm
going to talk about my addiction which
is uh why I'm here in downtown
um I felt like I needed to
uh tap into where did things start to go
awry for me and it happened
when my dad left my mom
and when I was 12 because right after
that
I started smoking weed
I started ditching school and I started
having sex and and that's the only three
things I cared about my dad left
before that you know I was a straight A
student went to Beverly Hills Catholic
School Good Shepherd and uh
you know the athlete played every sport
basketball baseball
football soccer every sport excelled in
all of them
[Music]
so you know it's it's it's it's that's
where it had that's where things start
to change for me when I was at 12. I've
I've I've worked on that and looked at
that
um
so
very reactive very rebellious from 12 to
18.
um uh smokes a lot of weed playing
basketball high school All-American uh
went to Loyal uh then transferred to
Hamilton then transferred to school
school called New Bridge which was a
small school and I dominated that League
because I came from a bigger League and
now I'm going to small school leagues
and I'm playing against kids that are
not even half as good as I am so I'm
scoring about 33 points a game I'm the
third leading scorer in the state of
California and I'm getting letters from
all the
colleges
I decided to go to St Mary's College and
I played basketball there my dream was
to be in the NBA I wanted to play in the
NBA I was very I was good I had a 42
inch vertical leap I can shoot from the
outside I was a strong dribbler very
good point guard
got invited to the best basketball camp
all the in in in in high school it's
called five star basketball camp
uh flew out to Pennsylvania took the bus
all the way up to Honesdale up in the
mountains and the the best
high school All-American kids there's
only three from each state got to go to
this Camp so I got Digger Phillips Rick
Pitino uh Pat Uh uh John John a guy from
Georgetown coach they're all there
scouting scouting all the high school
players
Howard garfinkel ran the camp he had a
book called five star and whatever he
rated you at all the college coaches
would look at this book and see what
kind of rating you got so if you had a
five-star rating you were division one
basketball player I got best player best
playmaker of the camp I wanted to go to
Notre Dame
um they took a guy named David Rivers
who ends up playing for the Lakers it
was a great point guard
um well I went to St Mary's and and in
my league you know we had Gonzaga and
Pepperdine
um you know and I played pretty bad the
coach that I didn't get along too well
so I didn't really feel like I got to
really
excel in that plus division one
basketball is tough
it's a big difference huge difference
so
um don't go to the NBA so my second
dream was I always wanted to be an actor
so I learned to uh
listen to my friends who were actors
like boy Kessner uh China Phillips
Michelle Phillips daughter from The
Mamas and Papas that's my ex-girlfriend
China
um so I'm hanging around with these
people uh smoking with these people uh
getting high with these people uh
um and uh so I started listening to
where they're where they're learning all
there's this acting stuff so I find out
and I go to Janet alhante I go to the
Beverly Hills Playhouse with milk
Lynette casalis study there Joanne Baron
studied there went to New York for two
years Terry Schreiber uh did a play with
uh it was called Thanksgiving cries
about juvenile delinquents I was one of
the main characters in there with in my
uh uh friend Ed Norton and Toby Maguire
so all three of this play together
Mark tessner is at the one of the the
plays one of the performances he casted
me for a soap called General Hospital
right I didn't have to audition for it
gave me the part Lynn Milano is my
manager at the time she books me signs I
signed a contract for one year General
Hospital
I got ridden off the show after one year
Harriet Greenspan cast me in uh Sunset
Beach
do that for six months
and then we got canceled for soap called
Passions right after that oh I did
Charmed with Alyssa Shannon Doherty and
and the other one whatever I did uh Lynn
Milano uh Alyssa's mom got me a part on
that she's good friends with spelling
anyways right after that they had the
actor strike at this time right before
that I have a beautiful home beautiful
wife beautiful son
um
house everything you know we have the
actor strike two years
two years without work two years
couldn't audition couldn't do [__] so I
started selling weed I start getting
depressed I start
things started dwindling I I had five
cars and now I'm down to one car now I'm
selling the house
um now I'm arguing with my wife
um what's going on you know
um you know acting isn't the only thing
you can do and you know
she wants me to find another career do
something else
um but my ego is not allowing it you
know actor strike's gonna be over soon
don't worry I'm gonna be getting a lot
of parts and things are going to be all
right
doesn't happen
so what happens is we move we sell the
house we move to a small apartment up on
La Brea near Sunset and
um it's different it's a whole new field
I'm going for jobs at the Gap the
Highland Mall just gets billed uh
Hollywood Highland markets build uh I go
in I go into uh the other not Gap but
the the other one I forget what the
their Partners the same thing but I said
[__] this you know I'm gonna say I'm a
visualist
so I lied and bullshitted and I got a
visual visualist job for um God what is
the name it's the Gap but there's
probably is that is exactly what it was
so
you know I I I [__] my way into that
I said yeah I went to fit them uh and I
learned how to do all this stuff so
visualist all he does is he comes in at
midnight and does all the displays all
the manicures the mannequins Gap has a
book that you have to do everything
accordingly but you can kind of add your
own little thing to it
it was a cool job man actually but the
problem is that
we're right in the heart of Hollywood
and Highland Hollywood and Highland at
this time there's at least 20 Pisces 20
Mexicans who have rock cocaine in their
mouth and every night when I got off
work to go across the street
and just you know because at this point
I'm I'm depressed I need a way out
my way out was getting a 20 Rock of
crack cocaine and rolling it up with
weed uh so my wife wouldn't know what I
was doing
um and that went on for about a year I
hit it I hit it um and I can't I just I
just had this really terrible feeling
inside and I just I needed help
and I didn't know what to do you know I
didn't know anything about programs
rehabs I knew nothing about that we
weren't taught in the 80s
we weren't taught that [__]
um so
I said I'm gonna I gotta tell her I
gotta tell her and I remember
I go on the balcony I smoke my last
Primo that's what I said to myself I'm
gonna go tell my wife I'm gonna wake her
up and I tell her everything that I've
been hiding this for a year and
I wake her up I'm crying
and I tell her
that uh
you know I got a problem I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm smoking raw cocaine with my with
the weed and I I can't stop
I can't stop
I I I can't stop I I want you to know
so we're crying together and stuff and I
I thought everything was going to be
fine a couple of days later I get a call
for an audition
um and I go
I'm feeling now I'm starting to feel
pumped again because the tractor strikes
now over and I get a call to go audition
for a TV show and
I go there I do a pretty good audition
not that great I didn't even get a call
back so I didn't do that great
um
but when I get home
everything's gone
the wife has taken my son
and herself and all their stuff and it
has left
and that was hard
my kid was everything to me man
um
so I thought you know
um this this this
disease if you want to call it or
addiction is very powerful
crack cocaine
ruined
my life
so to speak
um it's not over yet my life ain't over
yet but
a male for a long period of time crack
cocaine ruined my life it uh
took my son away from me it took my
family away from me
took my dignity away from me took it
took everything away from me my money my
everything my soul everything
um
and I find my place in the heart of
Hollywood on the brain sunset
and I'm just like so caught up in what's
going on in the streets at this point
this is like a year after my my wife has
left
and I'm back to uh the old other Mikey
which is an ex-gang member
from West LA and
18th Street says that no blacks can sell
any crack cocaine in Hollywood and I
found that ridiculous
how can how can how school do it come on
man this is that racial [__] again
that's that's the thing that really sets
me off more than anything else is
the hatred of somebody because the color
of their skin is the most ridiculous
thing I've ever ever had to deal with in
my life
just because you're brown or white or
yellow or green someone hates you
that's ridiculous man you'll hate
somebody because they did something you
hate somebody because you don't like
their ways hate somebody because they're
they're an [__]
don't hate somebody because of the color
of their [__] skin
that's that's just
ludicrous to me man ludicrous to me you
know I was raised not to see color I
love everybody I think every everybody
has everybody has this great potential
to be somebody great
everybody has that you know
you just gotta tap into it man
so I'm in Hollywood and I'm doing this
crazy [__] and I'm getting getting shot
at I get shot by 18th Street because I'm
in the middle of this [__] you know oh
Mikey's Mikey's turned his apartment
into [__] Central and they're coming out
and they're dealing with the 18th
streeters and
um
we're having meetings and talk abouts
and guys are getting killed uh one of my
one of my friends got killed at the at
Hollywood and Highland at the bus stop
they pulled up on him shot him with a
12-gauge shotgun killed him
um I'm walking around Hollywood with a
tech nine underneath my Dodger jacket a
Mossberg sawed-off shotgun sometimes or
a Beretta 380 and I'm just now that I
have this gun these guns I'm like
I feared nothing I fear nothing and
that's a bad [__] place
because when you fear nothing you tend
to do some stupid [__]
you tend to do some stupid [__] and I
did some stupid [__]
it gets short-lived because thank God
most people say you're crazy man now
thank God for muffin muffin is one of
the prostitutes up in Hollywood who got
[__] pissed off at me because I sold
her a 20 and it was like like the size
of a dime and she goes nuts she throws
[__] through my window but she goes down
the street at the Pollo Loco on it's on
Sunset near Western and starts to smoke
her crack her dime piece of crack
cocaine that I got her
little did she know is that the
Undercovers were sitting in the parking
lot
they arrest her she's a two Striker or
some [__] this is going to be her third
strike unless she gives them something
and she gave them something she says
that's Mikey
he's in there he's got a monster he's
got three guns he's got a tech nine
which during this time you have an
assault weapon because of the North
Hollywood shootout what happened in
there they said if you have any kind of
automatic weapons
in La you are looking at 15 to life
couldn't have those guns anymore because
of what those two guys did in that that
bank shootout in the valley
so
my friend the next
day my friend e calls me up he says
Mikey man man the Pollo Loco Park
parking lot is just filled with cops
they got the chalkboard out they got
everything what the [__] is going on
over there so I don't know I'm talking
to him on the phone so I walked down
there I live half a block from there
I've walked down I walk down there I'm
looking across the street I said e
that [__] it's not for me I am not Tony
Montana I'm not no big drug kingpin I'm
not any of that [__]
that's not for me so I go back into my
spot and I got a couple of girls there I
got a Barbie I got pretty eyes I got
some this other girl I'm naked on the
bed I got a plate full of crack cocaine
my cousins watching the door and and
we're smoking and [__] and all of a
sudden boom boom boom boom boom my
cousin opens up the [__] door
it's a regular door because I also had a
gate on the front of it he opens it up
and then slams it and runs upstairs and
jumps out the window
I'm like what the [__] is going on I
have no clue what happened I was because
I was in the middle of a hit getting a
[__] at the same time
did not
nothing nothing registered at that time
I'm enjoying my high I'm in this state
of euphoria that's great I don't want to
be disturbed
but some serious [__] was about to go
down
and I get up and pretty guys goes hide
the crack come on that's the police that
I snap out of it I said what the [__]
put on my clothes I opened the door and
literally there's like 15 of these beams
going through my gate all in the middle
of my chest I looked down I said hey hey
hey
open the door they're banging it because
they couldn't get the gate door open
they're banging they're banging I'll
open it you guys stop putting that
through your guns at me man I'm not
gonna open this [__] if you guys open
the door open the door this is the LAPD
open the door now boom boom boom boom
banging on it I said man stop man I'll
open it don't you [__] shoot
I opened the door and
two of the guys who were right there at
the front grab me like this and just
just take me outside and literally throw
me down on the ground I'm not in front
of my house and uh
yeah he was right it was they were they
were they were there to get me I I
couldn't believe it though it seemed
like the whole division
helicopter and everything
um
my cousin got away to this day we laugh
about it he gets away he jumps out the
[__] window and gets away they head
the whole [__] place around it
anyways that uh I was looking at 15 to
life because of the the one weapon the
tech N9 was an automatic weapon I was I
had to fight a case of pimping and
pandering which also started the 15 to
life they call it
um
human trafficking now
drug selling
I was looking at I think 30 years for
that
um it was it was huge
um
but
you know I have this white dad
who loves his son very much
um who comes to the courtroom with his
trophies is his son's trophies to show
the judge that you know his son is not
this bad person that the D.A is making
him out to be that his son
is a a great basketball player went to
Catholic school was an altar boy
was an actor was a lot of things before
this happened and the reason why his son
now is is in this kind of trouble is
because he was unaware of his addiction
where his addiction would take him
which is very true
if you told me that I was going to get
surrounded by the Hollywood Police
before I took that hit of crack cocaine
and I was gonna have guns I was gonna
lose everything and all my cars in my
wife my house and everything I probably
wouldn't have took that hit
I probably wouldn't have took that hit
um
but like I said before there's no there
was there wasn't too much of that going
around I mean the only thing I could
remember was Nancy Reagan's
Ugg for drugs campaign and that kind of
stuff and but it wasn't how it is now
how they're making people aware of you
know this is a disease you can get help
we have passages we have Claire
Foundation we have a lot a lot of
resources to get get you the help you
need the only problem is that with drugs
there is no cure to the disease the only
cure that that I see that works is is
abstinence
was absence mean it means uh
not doing
is that that's that's all you get you
don't get a pill you don't get a shot
okay it's just not doing
yeah Mike yeah that's that's all that's
all you get buddy not doing it
so you have to figure out ways to
um not do it and so they say go to
meetings and they say do the 12 steps
and they say
talk to your sponsor they say you know
all these these these cliche and great
things that uh um that that help
um but it it takes more than that for me
it did
um so
I get sentenced what happens to the case
I get my dad my lawyer my dad comes gets
me a great lawyer my best friend who now
is 30 years cleaning the program comes
and talks to my behalf
um and
um you know I got two years in prison
I went to a prison called Donovan which
is down near San Diego and basically
that prison is they it's more it's not
like
uh it's not like Folsom or Soledad or
any of those it's more a lot of the drug
addicts uh who get cases go down there
but on top of that I had I did the two
years there and then I had to do two
years in residential treatment
afterwards
so
um
I'm feeling good I'm feeling like okay
this is this is this is this is a good
time to change my life get it back on
track because at this point I have
nothing
um my family's like they don't want to
talk to me anymore my brothers they
don't want to talk to me I'm the bad
seed all of a sudden
um but
I served my time then I go to a rehab
called beta shuva which is a Jewish uh
uh uh rehab in West LA
it's a great great place because they
really take they cover you and take care
of you all the way up to a point to
where you can take care of yourself
um Rabbi Mark great guy uh I don't think
he's there anymore
so I did I do that and then I started
getting confidence and I said I got to
do something in my life I want to do
something that has meaning that's
purpose that gives me uh motivation and
so I said
since I never got the [__] uh taught
about drugs and rehabs at a young age
that's who I want to help I want to help
the teenagers I want to go to so I
started going to Hollywood and all the
people in the the Bandos up there I
started talking to all the kids
um I started saying look you can get a
job because a lot of kids were not from
from here they're from out of state
wanting to be an actor or a musician and
doesn't pan out within 10 months and so
they don't know what to do and they end
up being broke and not knowing what to
do so I started to start doing a program
up there where I would take the homeless
kids I would get something to eat chop
it up we talk about some things we go do
workouts at LA Fitness up there
um and then I take them to the library I
would do uh help them do their resumes
I'd advocated for these young kids
because no one else would
um also I gave them some tools
um let them know you know what you got a
drug problem this is what you can do to
get help
if you want it because it's not going to
work if you don't want to do it
so my best friend and I start a company
called Universal teen Crisis
Intervention and we start
saving kids all over the U.S
we get really really popular really
really big Michelle Obama calls me and
go talk to the kids in Chicago
then flew me to Washington DC talked to
the kids in DC
Annie gets wind of it
and now I got my own TV show
called the extractors
um
and you know I
I I I couldn't even thought of sort of
dream something up like this
and I'm just laying there I'm like wow
I lost everything I had everything I
lost everything and now I'm about to get
everything back again
cool and I'm doing something positive
I'm talking to kids who are gang members
talking to kids who are drug addicts
and they don't have to listen to me but
at least I feel good because I'm giving
them something you know at least you
know I never got that no no no no no
guys came to talk to me and say hey Mike
you could go to Claire or you can go to
Acton and you can get some help you have
a disease I didn't get any of that [__]
so now I can give this to them and I'm
feeling good and I'm I'm going all over
the U.S parents are calling me I'm on
Facebook and I got all this big
following Dr Drew all these people Annie
so we do eight episodes of the
extractors
and the show's about the work that me
and my best friend Evan bulla James does
with these kids
um
it's great it was awesome I was getting
paid good money
um I wasn't doing it for the money but
now this weird thing starts to happen
and now you know
um I am doing it for the money uh
because before it's non-profit but now a
E's paying for the cases and their pain
is pretty good 10 000 a episode I'm
getting and that's rare because they
usually don't when the reality TV
they'll usually only want to give you 5
000 an episode if it goes into second
season then you can get some more
um by time we shoot the eighth episode
um my ego my head is out to here
I'm not going to meetings anymore
I'm not talking to my sponsor anymore
I am
Irish Mike the head of the Teen
interventionist
I don't need to go to no meetings
I don't need to do no steps
this is all ego talking
so ego
in the program
we call it edging God out
um
is what got me
in relapse mode
ego
so when I go to my mom's house which is
in South Central where as I did most of
my smoking of crack cocaine a lot of it
and uh this is a certain girl named
Keisha over there who I was always
wanted to smoke with it never got to
she's sitting at the bus stop
I'm 10 years clean I'm clean I'll never
do crack again ever I would challenge
people people would say Mike don't say
that I said what the [__] you talking
about that's 10 years I got 10 years Man
10 years please
okay and I look at her
she's like oh I'm so proud of you the TV
show I would love it they're doing great
work Mike can you change your life
you're such an inspiration to everybody
you know comes out of my mouth you got
one
you got one Keisha what are you talking
about Mikey you got one what the [__]
are you talking about I'm not going to
be responsible like I'm not giving you
[__] I'm not giving you nothing like I'm
not going to be the downfall of your
[__] 10 years in this TV show and
[__] no way Say Jimmy Keisha
give me a hit just like that it's like
the devil
give me a hit scared she went like that
she flinched ah [__] all right I'm here
[__] here
let me out of the car I don't even here
I want to be responsible for this she
gives it to me I didn't get out I don't
care leave the pipe
I take that first hit and
it's 10 years clean now
I'm like whoa
and everything got silent I'm sitting in
my BMW
got real silent
yeah
you know they always talk about
you know your Monsters Inside and you
don't want you don't want to let them
out again because once you let them out
again he's very [__] hard to get out
get back in
and they're right
um
I go from that hit
Drake Skid Row
downtown
this is three years ago
and I haven't left
I'm still here
so
but I'm not done yet you know I'm not
done yet
I'm an adequate who's fighting their
disease
I I will always fight this man
I'll fight it for the rest of my life
um
this relapse was really hard really
[__] hard because you know I got all
these kids these parents on Facebook and
my best friend season two is not going
to happen now because Irish Mike has
relapsed
Dr Drew doesn't want to do season two
now
I'm the cause of season two napkin
going into production and it's my best
friend you know she created all this
[__] and I let him down
it's just tremendous tremendous amount
of [__] guilt
finally got my son back in my life
after six years of not talking to me
finally got my mom back in my life
for a long time not talking to me
my brothers could trust me again my dad
I made amends to him because we have the
same name so I got one of his checkbooks
and I was to him and I wrote a lot of
checks off about close to thirty
thousand dollars in checks I finally
paid him off with the money I made from
the extractors and the work I was doing
you know all this [__] that I got back
just all down the drain again
and I sat on that for a long time it's
about six months just getting high just
getting high just down here just getting
high getting all right Mikey no yeah I'm
just getting out just getting how I get
high you know just going through the
motions but inside I was dying inside I
was [__] black it was it was really
dark place dark place
so you know I'm here
I'm fighting my disease
um I have moments of uh where I'm not
smoking crack cocaine you know I but you
know I
I'm Not In and Out in and out and um
it's just it's it's a it's it's tough
man it's really tough I I know what I'm
gonna need to do I'm going to have to go
into a treatment facility just to get
away from here for 30 days to separate
myself from the drug get it out of my
system and then from there I can go back
to doing what I used to do I can go back
to go to three or four meetings a week
get a sponsor do the steps
it's it's boring as hell
but it kept me clean it kept me clean
what do you think people outside of
you know people who are not addicts
don't understand about drug addiction
because you've been on top you've been
down the bottom even back and forth
yeah
um and you know my mom's one of those
and she's from it's a choice my son it's
your choice it's the choices you make
yeah but you know
the people who have cancer did they have
a choice
no
and this is what I've been taught and
believe this is a disease
[Music]
um
it's
so someone who's a normie who doesn't
really get high that much who can put
the stuff down and not do it again for
six months is way different than me
I've crossed over that Plateau as you
talk about in the book when you reach a
certain point in your addiction and
you've gone past it you have now became
you now have the ism you now have the
disease you now have the addiction which
is completely different I can't when I
take one
when I take a hit
I can't stop
as bad as I want to stop
it won't allow me to stop
um
and it's all because
they say it's It Centers in your
thinking it centered it's centered it
attacks your brain
um yeah it really does
um it works it's it's you know it's
baffling and Powerful they say that in
CA all the time and it's true it's [__]
you know I'll I'll I I will I'm about to
leave downtown and go back home to my
dad's where I can stay as long as I'm
not getting high I can stay there when I
get sick of this [__] and when I'm about
to leave all of a sudden someone can
someone needs a ride to go buy an ounce
and they're gonna give me a hundred
dollars and also an eight ball
really
right when I'm ready to leave and give
all this [__] up that [__] like that
happens
all the time
I'm not gonna buy anything I don't have
any money good that's great I don't need
it I'll find a dime on the ground just
all of a sudden
you know it's it's just weird how that
[__] happens is it as simple as just
having a drug addiction you have this
propensity to use and not stop or is it
more tied into your self-worth and what
you believe you deserve in life and
is it something deeper
it is deeper
um
that's what I talk about in the
beginning how where everything changed
for me
I became that I think I I I I I started
working on my ISM at 12 my dad left
I was very rebellious very
my they say don't smoke weed I'm going
to smoke weed if your dad doesn't want
you then
why should you deserve better right yeah
that right
my mouth says when my dad left before he
got into the Porsche
I'm on the ground holding his feet
holding his legs don't go dad crying
I don't remember that but that's what
she said it has happened
yeah yeah I think the kids me and my
brothers I did blame ourselves
we did a little bit I think we did I
thought I thought for a while
he had too many of us
we're stressing his ass out he want he
don't want him you know he ain't happy
at all
he had too many six boys they kept
trying to we're all a year apart too
in a that's a tough crowd you know
dinner tables fights we would have the
things that we Chase I I lit all of
Coldwater Canyon on fire by accident you
know we're playing with matches in the
back we were bad kids man we were
nothing you know
we we did did our we did a lot of stuff
we were very mischievous we got into
everything everything and uh
you know
um yeah we blamed ourselves yeah
for a while but my dad would say you
know
it was it was hard because I love my dad
but then my mom would tell us all the
stuff that was going on in the in the
the proceedings the Accord the divorce
and how he's hiding money he's hiding
money
dad says he doesn't have any money ma he
has money in these Swiss accounts he's
hiding money so he doesn't have to give
it to you guys
it's not true I'll give you guys money
I'll pay for when you guys are with me
but I'm not giving your mom nothing you
know it was that whole that that
separation of divide we never saw them
argue
there was never a fight in the house
just all of a sudden he's he's leaving
and all of a sudden we weren't eating
steaks anymore we were having tencent
bread and you know government cheese
it's very very different
I felt different my clothes were
different my hair was different all of a
sudden
I had afros because they couldn't afford
haircuts and all of a sudden
um yeah these these things are oh man
teenage years
are tough man tough tough tough times
for some you know I feel sorry for kids
who get bullied
man they because
whatever happens to you at those young
age traumatizes you and will affect you
later on and you not know it though you
know unless you really like deep dig
down deep and I worked with a therapist
to do that you know and that's and
that's where we got to and I was like
yeah that's it
because that's when everything changed
my dad left and as of now
Aldi
57 57 and you're still down here smoking
I'm back down here smoking
different but it's not so different
because
I I have a motor home
I still have my things what am I smarter
now
I don't know it's it's a little scary
um uh you know I got everything I have
in the normal world but I but I don't
have my family you know my brothers
ain't coming down to see me they come
down there and they're yelling from
across the road O'Connors don't live
like this
get out of there Mike
come home which just adds more shame a
little bit that's what they're trying to
do I think but
they don't have the ism
they can't they can't
and we were we're regimented my dad was
our coach
um very strong-willed and self self
strong will all that [__] is out the
window when you are in the addicted
to drugs because how many times have I
said
I'm not going to do this [__] no morning
all of a sudden the pipes in my hand
I'm not gonna spend my last money on
that all of a sudden I have no money in
my pocket
I'm not going to sell my [__] BMW for
no [__] crack all of a sudden the
dope driving around my BMW
you know and I'm like sitting there
smoking I'm like what the [__] how that
happens
what the [__] man why'd you let me stop
God damn you [__] because they
always like yeah it's a good idea yeah
you get a good price oh yeah he's gonna
give you that big old bag of rocks and
then yeah we're all gonna smoke
come on
yeah and when it was all over they don't
want you around you know it's like
the people in the drug world are
cutthroat they will [__] they will
take you out in a heartbeat
and a heartbeat that's what I see after
doing all these talks is
for you to ex like you come from a good
background yeah and you had a you had a
great life great wife yeah great house
all that sounds like career
for you to accept something like this
and these kind of Associates yeah
says something about your self-worth
yeah and that's why I believe it's got
something to do with maybe when your dad
split
it left you feeling like oh [__] I
really don't deserve anything better and
you had success so you so you're yeah
walking both sides of the fence yeah but
at some point something happens to you
and next thing you know you're your wife
leaves you like your dad did and uh here
you are yeah
yeah
it tumbled real fast
um and I think you're you're right we're
all fragile yeah we are I don't I try
not I don't I don't I don't look at that
because I got this
machismo this thing this fear nothing
guy inside there that uh it's not gonna
happen to me but it does happen to me I
had 12 bikes all of them stolen it does
happen to me I got Sucker Punch I got
puppies it doesn't happen to me this guy
chased me hit me with his gun it does
happen to me what are you doing walking
around Hollywood with a Mossberg shotgun
yeah
yeah I mean but look I'm not doing that
today but back then I did do that
because I said well okay this is how
these [__] want to play the
game I'll show you how you play the game
you play you guys do it half-ass I'll
show you I walked around I was taking
people the guy any dope dealer that had
dope and didn't have a gun got his dope
tooken from me and all I did was open up
my jacket
give it here what
oh come on Mikey come on man I need this
come on man don't take it man hand it
over man
now because I be I I hated the people
how they acted in the drug world I was
naive to it I didn't know that you give
a girl 100 and she doesn't come back I
didn't know that
what you guys didn't tell this [__]
she's done it before and you allowed me
to give her the money
she's not coming back Mikey you tell me
now
so all these things in the drug world I
was very naive to you know the sharing
of the pipe was the pipe was the The
Almighty uh uh chalice like oh no and if
you pushed it they will kill you if you
push someone else's pipe I mean it was
ridiculous
I said that's that's a that's a 10 cent
piece of glass why are you guys putting
so much power on that [__] man
I don't know what you talking about man
it's my pipe man though you know this
piece of glass I'll break it go buy
another one what the [__] you guys
giving okay I didn't understand all that
[__] I do now
I've become one of those people ask me
can you probably know hell no you can't
use my pipe oh hell no I ain't got no
nope nope you can't use my lighter
either no no no you don't come back no
I'm just like them now just like and
that's scary what would you say is the
most important thing you've learned in
your life all these ups and downs
keep your head up
um and just
believe in yourself
know that you know
if you get up the next morning
that's a good sign that uh
shit's gonna be all right
if you don't get up the next morning it
is game over Dude game over all right
Mike thank you so much for sharing your
story
thanks a lot I appreciate it great talk
all right